I want brand loyalty I think long form
is a way for that in two years you grew
over 500 000 subscribers over a hundred
and thirty million video views and
because of really focusing not just on
short form but also on long-form content
like I said storytelling just being
different as the world gets more and
more quick Snappy we're gonna be
yearning for those things that make us
feel emotion again I feel that I am in
this for the long-term relationship with
my audience
welcome back to the think media podcast
I'm super fired up to have Pat Flynn
sharing his latest YouTube strategies
and it's pretty wild because in two
years you grew over five hundred
thousand subscribers over 130 million
video views and as a result this has led
to now an event that has sold a thousand
tickets without any advertising to
actually being known by bigger Brands
and people of influence all because of
starting a YouTube channel and because
of really focusing not just on short
form although we're going to be covering
that but also on long-form content and
Pat Flynn is really a marketing genius
he is the author of books like super
fans and will it Fly and he's going to
be dropping some wisdom it's going to be
cool to catch up today Pat how's it
going great that was one take dude
you're busy I mean we're out here uh and
it's been fun to hang out with you every
year this is like our annual Meetup at
Social Media Marketing world and just so
grateful for you and your impact in on
our community and everything you're
doing but break down what's been
happening what's the channel and how did
you grow 500 000 subscribers in just two
years it's in 200 videos by the way wow
so the power of Storytelling is really
what it's about so I'm not first to
create videos about Pokemon in fact it's
just been a thing for a while and
typically people who are influencers in
the world of Pokemon on YouTube are
opening packs and they're making the
drama exciting and they might get a big
poll or or they might not there's a lot
of big names who I owe a lot of things
to I wasn't in the Pokemon back in the
day I'm brand new to it Collectibles
sort of took a big surge during the
pandemic and I I went along with it
um but then after consuming all this
amazing Pokemon content on YouTube after
getting involved in these communities
even being moderators for some of their
channels I was just like
think I could bring something new here
to the space so that's what I did and so
in January of 2021 myself uh my producer
Dan Patrick Norton who I think you know
as well as uh our editor Zach and Jay on
the Discord we just kind of put our
heads together and started creating
content that we thought people would
want to watch and it all really comes
down to just like I said storytelling
and and just being different right and
you know the fact that I didn't know
anything about Pokemon I knew I had to
take a a special role in this space
because I couldn't compete on other
people's collections they've been
collecting for longer than I so I can't
compete with those people I don't know a
lot about the the topic and there's
people who are experts in this space so
I had to come in from a learn with me
approach right and I think you know Gary
vaynerchuk talks about that a lot like
working in public just kind of
journaling and bringing people along for
the ride and if you can combine that
with good storytelling people can
actually relate better to you because I
mean they can teach you a thing and then
with you there's so many unlocks here I
think one thing that's fascinating is as
Gary calls a document don't create for
anybody that feels like they're not an
expert which you are not it is possible
to get in the game with the learn with
me approach I think what's also
fascinating is you're like the ultimate
hybrid because I feel like think media
podcast you know our community really
doesn't lean as much towards the
entertainment side of things you know
not our creators are not aspiring to be
like a Mr Beast a lot of business owners
entrepreneurs looking for leads clients
and sales or people that are getting you
with a hobby and they're monetizing that
moms and DIY channels but what's
fascinating about you is you've got this
whole smart passive income business
podcasts and brand and YouTube channel
and you've been known for affiliate
marketing but you've also been a great
entrepreneur because you've built some
automation a lot of automation into that
team and systems which allowed you to
with all your marketing knowledge and
how to send out and how to have a niche
and with the ability to then take
something that was new to your life that
tied into your passion and your family
you literally launch a whole new project
because you're kind of a weird guy in
this sense you know in a sense where you
were the smart passive income guy but
now literally you have a Pokemon
conference
with a thousand tickets sold already
with no advertising on the back end of
this YouTube channel a new brand
basically your best-selling author and
speaker but yet you got you're about
Pokemon so I'm at the bridge I want to
connect for our community is is that
there's not even maybe just the business
that you're doing right now but there's
also that as you learn the skills of
YouTube of marketing of what are you
also passionate about is what's maybe a
future business you want to launch a
future project a second Channel you
should do all things at once maybe break
down the Journey of your Brands and your
projects because I think some people
might think I need to write a book start
a podcast start a brand make online
courses you've done all the above but
you didn't do it all in one year yeah
it's an iterative approach and the way I
like to think about it I actually have
to break this down to teach other people
stuff because the more stuff I was able
to do over time yeah the more people
started to see all those things and try
to do all of them at the same time I
gotta remember I gotta tell people and
even with this channel right it's just
started two years ago and it's so big
now and they're like oh it's an
overnight success I'm like no I started
on YouTube in 09. this challenge has
happened to be created in like year 12.
right so it's been a long time to come
but I am a very I'm very much a person
who wants to do all the things but if I
did all the things I would accomplish
nothing yeah and so I have a rule called
the 20 itch Rule and this isn't anything
new that's just the name I put on it uh
to be able to share this but it's
eventually it's basically 80 of my time
is dedicated to the things that I've
already committed to things I said yes
to already 20 of my time is dedicated to
experimentation but trying things they
may not work and that's okay and
typically it's not a zero-sum anything
because I'm always learning and
reapplying to the other things too so
this is my way to place boundaries
around the Curiosity that I have to try
something new from 2017 to 2019 if
you've been watching think media for a
while you might have heard of something
called The Switch pod that was my 20 of
time between 2017 and 2019 that's mostly
automated now and Caleb my partner's
doing a really good job of keeping that
um and we're still making sales and
that's going but I needed something new
because I want to scratch that itch but
again doing it in a very purposeful
Manner and again even if it failed
that's okay this one Pokemon one happens
to be the most successful 20 of my time
that I've done but this isn't new um
Gary vaynerchuk talks about this ramit
said t d dedicates Fridays to creative
day in his business Google allows for
their employees one day of the week to
just build new random things that aren't
you know what they were assigned to do
so I've adopted that into my creativity
and it's a way for me to control
all the things I want to do yeah
um and right now I'm having a ton now
what's cool about that is that if you're
doing your 20 on something like your
Pokemon Channel you still have these
other things where you're learning all
these insights you're learning
click-through rates and marketing and
storytelling that then applies you write
a new book and so you're probably
constantly getting better at Psychology
and thinking about marketing and
positioning and so having that creative
margin 20 rule is going to enhance
everything else you do for sure I mean
there is this philosophy of just do one
thing right there's a book about that I
I preached that for a while but that hey
I just can't do one thing right I like
to say I'm a part of all trades master
of fun but also that's funny uh but you
also have developed the skill of
Delegation true yes and automation
important and
profitability so that you could reinvest
dollars into you switchpod is a physical
product you launched that you put a lot
of time into you got it to lift off but
then you also now have the way it's able
to run is because of Caleb and because
of systems because of the heavy lifting
up front right A 3pl or a third-party
Logistics which we ship all those switch
pods to that then just take care of all
those things like we remove as much of
the work that's required from us as
humans on the team as possible and then
part of that is also making decisions on
what we should and shouldn't do right we
could get into Best Buys in fact we
tried that and we found that the process
which is so convoluted and taking so
much energy that it wasn't even worth
the potential end reward there so we're
just sticking with our Shopify account
and our Amazon account to sell the
switch pod so being very disciplined is
a very important thing and sometimes you
don't know what to say yes to or to say
no to until later and again being 15
years into this journey now it's it's
it's clear for me but it's a language
I've learned over time and it's one you
can learn from people that you follow
online faster but the best way to learn
is to just try and fail yeah so I want
to talk about long-form video in a bit
but I want to stay on this and talk a
little bit about maybe even some
principles from your book will it fly
because you launched this new project
and someone's listening to this they're
getting excited because maybe they felt
constrained and they feel niched down
maybe they don't have enough team
systems automation profitability to add
more on because I'd cause more stress
but assuming they do or they've got some
level of that or they're just going to
take their 20 time what is your what is
a few principles for thinking about
starting a second project from the
standpoint of you're very intelligent
you didn't know if this Pokemon thing
would work but there's probably some
principles where it at least had a shot
to it at least maybe past some of the
will it Fly criteria and what is that
framework yeah I get I I want to give
things the best chance to succeed yeah
if you're just creating and guessing you
you're leaving it up and there are some
things you can do to stack things in
your favor so that you have a little bit
more percentage opportunity and so with
this channel we didn't just Dive Right
In and start filming right which is very
common to do and oftentimes it's like
just like Seth Godin says like just ship
it well you still need to know what
direction you want that ship to go right
so we just did a lot of research and I
did a lot of research being involved in
these communities first being a
moderator of different channels and
really once I finally got into those
spaces having direct mostly direct
message on Instagram uh conversations
with other fans of those channels just
to ask them what they liked about them
what they didn't like what do you wish
existed what do you think there should
be more of uh this is part of the will
it Fly process is just analysis of who's
in the space that you want to
um you know reach out to and you know
that's really important because you
might find through that research that
it's actually not something you want to
do anymore because of what you've
learned from that research I found that
that gave me more energy to then create
and then from there uh it was it was a
lot of taking what I what I've learned
on my other channel which was a lot of
mistakes not being hyper focused and not
focusing on titles and thumbnails as
much as I should have wanting to make
sure that I do it right this time so
there was a lot of research into well
what thumbnails in the Pokemon space
seem to be working really well which
ones aren't working really well not
getting into Super analysis with like
spreadsheets and stuff but just noticing
patterns and then deploying those and
seeing what happened uh but mostly
conversations and you'll find that the
first half of will it Fly is all about
diving into those communities and
discovering who those people are and
what are their why are they here I mean
I I discovered through that process that
most of the audiences that watched
Pokemon channels were men between 25 and
35. these were people who in 1999 and in
2000 when Pokemon came out these were
the kids who were going to spend their
allowance on Pokemon these guys are now
older now with money
and they're diving back into it and
reliving that Nostalgia so now I can
understand that when I'm creating a
video for somebody wow that's that's
super fascinating and so of course we'll
link that up in the show notes will it
Fly is the book if you're thinking about
launching a new project and really a
business like will it be a profitable
business will it Fly and uh some
powerful insights there you're going to
do a keynote all about long-form video
which is fascinating because the trend
right now YouTube shorts reels is
blowing up everywhere everyone's
obsessed with vertical video but of
course long form hasn't really gone
anywhere but it's kind of being
forgotten about and it's less talked
about and you're literally the closing
keynote of this conference break it down
what is your opinion first of all maybe
at a high level short form versus long
form both are awesome by the way don't
think I hate short form but I love the
ability to go deep and you can only go
so deep in a minute long snack and
that's that's the analogy I like to use
with short form is like a snack it's
like a rhesus pieces or Reese's
buttercup amazing I want more but then
if I have too much I feel stuffed and
sick and that sometimes we feel that
when we over absorb too much shorts or
reels or tick tocks right and it's like
the equivalent of you as a creator for
snacks or short form is like you're
you're you have the house that the
Halloween kids are coming up to they get
you the snack from you and then they
move on it's like I want to be the chef
who has the restaurant that people come
to and can sit down and have an
experience not only do they have an
experience they go home and tell
everybody about that experience and then
they invite them to come too right I
feel that I am in this for the long-term
relationship with my audience I want
brand loyalty I think long form is a way
for that
um right long form is where brand
loyalty comes from now both work over
time I actually start out my keynote
talking about two creators one's a short
form Creator one's a long one uh the
first one his name's Aaron most people
don't know him but they know his pet
Siegel Steven and he's a person who
feeds the seagull every day and he's
like training it to you know come into
the house and like it's his pets pet
Stephen Stephen seagull see uh but then
there's another Creator who's very
similar his name is Brady he has a
channel but people don't know Brady they
know Leon the lobster the lobster that
he rescued from a grocery store and
raised it as a pet and this series went
super viral and that's on long form and
you'll find that for each of those
channels whenever they talk about
Stephen or Leon that there's just a
plethora of views but you can feel a
little bit more of a relationship with
Leon and the lobster and there's merch
and there's other things that go along
with that and again from from a loyalty
standpoint I mean if you've seen friends
like he's her lost right like it's
that's a stupid joke but I'm Gonna Keep
It In the keynote anyway because I have
a gift to support that and it's too late
to change it but uh you know for for
Leon Lobster and for long form that's
where loyalty is and you said I think I
think as the world gets more and more
just quick Snappy snacky
um we're gonna be yearning for those
things that make us feel emotion again
and that's not to say you can't do that
in the short I mean I've watched some
shorts that have made me cry because
they're really good at storytelling but
over the long term especially with brand
loyalty and building super fans I think
long form is the way to go and if you
understand how YouTube works with title
thumbnail algorithm and and just
essentially replacing algorithm with
audience uh there's some amazing
opportunities there do you upload shorts
on deep pocket monster we have in the
past now this was before YouTube bridged
shorts with Longs and and we got
penalized for that essentially because
our shorts were taking over the spots
that our Longs would have been suggested
so we saw a ton of views with shorts but
we didn't see people coming back after
those views number one and number two it
started to reach parts of the world that
weren't my audience people who were
commenting on these Pokemon shorts like
these guys are stupid why are they
paying money for kids cardboard board so
it's a getting reach but it's also kind
of toxic because it's not tapping into
the heart of the community it's just
tapping into viewers that are but we did
get subs from those and some of those
subs have went on to become fans but our
long-form videos have a way of just
riding on the YouTube algorithm to find
exactly who the perfect viewer is right
for exactly the kind of content that we
create to a point where I'm getting
recognized on the street now people are
coming to an event that has never been
done before uh to literally sending me
messages that the content has saved
their life to families saying we spend
every Monday night with you live and
they just sit down eat dinner watch deep
pocket monster and it's a part of their
routine and somebody reached out to me
the other day and it was like Pat it's
so cool that in 30 years when I have
conversations with my son we're going to
talk about the Nostalgia of watching
deep pocket monster geez it's just like
that's wild dude nobody said that about
a top five tips for Facebook on my other
YouTube channel right right because
those don't tell stories that's
information yeah now I'm trying to learn
from deep pocket monster to teach and
tell story infotainment on the pathland
channel and that seems to be working a
little bit better yeah right not just
listicles and such but actually bringing
some story into it so I could take a top
five Facebook tips approach but I can
turn that into something that now is
more of an experiment where you don't
know what the end is going to be like
and there is something at stake perhaps
so I'm I'm actually learning a lot from
the Pokemon channel that I'm bringing
into my other stuff too storytelling is
a big buzzword I've heard from people
here I've said hey what do you want to
learn at Social Media Marketing world
and people said I want to get better at
storytelling I want to learn
storytelling and now you're talking
about long form but you're saying the
magic there is long form with a story is
there any initial framework that you can
give us of what are the elements of
story and even on our next YouTube video
where it might feel a little bit
overwhelming if we're not going to go to
the level of editing or even time what
are some maybe many improvements where
we could bring story into a more
business business context where we're
going live for 35 minutes doing a
presentation and be better at
storytelling yeah great question so
there's a few Frameworks that I like to
work off of I mean if you are telling
the story about a person and what
they've done the hero's journey
framework is really amazing here's where
they were here's what their struggles
were here's the adventure they went on
to discover something new and the
challenges that happened here's the
guide hopefully you coming into place
and then now here they are after all
that slaying the dragon look at how much
better their life is now that framework
is an archetype that exists in most
stories that we all fall in love with
and that's one that we could adopt for
our businesses for sure if we wanted to
especially if we're telling the story
about a student of ours or a client or
something I would highly recommend
reading a book called Building Story
brand with Donald Miller it basically
yeses you how to do that right your
student is the hero of the story and you
become the guy that then everybody else
wants to go through that same Journey
with yes right so the heroes archetype's
really great I think even more simple
especially if you're just teaching
something is just trying to ask yourself
like why is this important and what can
like what's an outcome that we don't
know the result yet until we do this
thing I was helping a person the other
day who does Facebook as on YouTube and
he was like oh I want to create a really
compelling story out of teaching this
new feature about YouTube like how do I
how do I do that it seems fake and I'm
like can you just put maybe a hundred
bucks up and say hey I'm gonna spend 100
bucks on this new tool and it's either
going to work better or worse than what
I used to do and already he's like
now I have to watch this video like that
makes total sense yeah right it's a hook
there's a hook there's something what's
yeah how did he lose the hundred what
happened with it and you pull them right
into the beginning rather than even just
being I'm about to teach you about this
new feature right right I did a video on
my paplin channel
um that that's a huge point though I'm
not starting videos anymore ever
explaining what I'm about to talk about
I'm just gonna get right into it yeah so
I did a video for podcasters on my
paplin channel uh using chat gbt so
before I would have looked at the camera
and said hey guys in this video I'm
going to teach you three things that you
can do with chat GPT to increase your
speed with your podcast or something
like that right and then boom let's go
the first shot is me in chat GPT typing
what questions should I ask Tim Ferriss
for my podcast and and now you already
are like well what are those questions
and then I just keep taking further what
are some personal questions I could ask
Tim Ferriss and then after a minute and
a half of really intriguing stuff hey
guys Chad GPT that's what we're talking
about today that was tip number one
here's tip number two and it's just the
retention graph is flat from the start
as a result of that which is which is
like if you ever go into analytics
you'll often find that a certain like a
large percentage of people drop off
right at the beginning yes and then it
flat it's flat if you're if you're good
why not take the beginning out and just
get to that part where it's already flat
and it's we're using a lot of data and
stuff to analyze what to do and what not
to do and that was that was a big one
for us on the Pokemon Channel and I'm
now incorporating that into more of an
information channel is there any
specific books or Ted Talks or podcasts
or movies that have helped you become a
better Storyteller that you'd also
recommend all TED Talks number one all
of them all of them and the whole talk
like Ted which is a book about the
structure of a TED talk right I'm simply
studying the structure of a TED Talk
itself 17 minutes watch any Ted Talk and
ask yourself how are they starting this
fit this this talk they never say hey
guys in this time no they're like I was
five years old and they're pointing to
something and it's like you're you don't
have time to wonder whether this is
worth your time because you're already
yeah exactly and there's some I mean
like yeah like the year that my
grandfather passed away was the darkest
though like some statement and then
you're like oh it pulls your heart
immediately
now it was
1986 or you know and the stock market
just crashed I'm staring at my computer
you know or whatever yeah and you don't
want to you don't necessarily even have
to script it per se and you like just be
yourself and tell the story like you
would tell anybody else right and then
you can add on all the tricks that we
know about YouTube to you know add
b-roll and engaging text and you know
zooms like all that kind of stuff you
pick up those things over time but you
could have a like if you watch any of
those Leon the lobster videos yeah it's
like terrible quality
and it's just like a long run-on shot of
some like his first video was like oh
you could have edit that way better it
didn't matter because the title was
um like can I raise a grocery store
Lobster to be a pet 18 million views
usually like a year yeah because that's
a question like you
you either thought about that before and
never figured out or you're like I
wonder compelling topic right yeah and
now it's two years later Leon's still
alive yeah and he's healthy looking like
in the beginning he did some good things
though his thumbnail in the beginning
the Leon the lobster you saw that giant
rubber band on the claw like that's very
like visual oh that is a grocery store
lobster right and then um you see like
when they when he snaps it off you see
like discoloration harass claw but then
over time you know uh and the guy Brady
mentions it he's like oh look at his
claw like it looks healthy again he's
actually moving it and you're just like
I'm not getting choked up it's a grocery
store like sure I'm I would I eat
lobster and uh I love Lobster but now
I'm like I'm I'm questioning my
decisions I'm thinking about the
emotions of the lobster Lee has had that
impact on people I'm like I'm like that
Lobster is a person
um that poor claw don't name your food
that you're about to eat yeah man Larry
the Lobster uh Leon Leon Leon man bro my
heart is pitter patter what else TED
Talks
um storytelling I mean there are some
people who who
um I mean you've taught storytelling on
your channel before there's a lot of
other great YouTubers but I I feel like
as opposed to even just looking for
those stories and and like what do you
consume on YouTube and why do you
consume it what about whatever it is
you're watching in any genre and what's
the structure right what movies that you
go I don't know what it is but I don't
care about the characters or why is it
flat or has a grab me or what about this
pulled me in oh yeah Caden right like
like randomly that like we're in a space
that looks like a airport I'm thinking
of the terminal with Tom Hanks and why
do people love that movie it's about a
guy who ended up living in an airport
terminal because his country was in war
and he wasn't he was kind of an
in-betweener at that point but like the
best moments of that are like when he's
putting you know ketchup on a cracker
because that was the only food he could
afford and and it's like oh my gosh like
he's like trying to figure it out in
some creative way and how can I in my
videos
using Facebook make the equivalent of a
cracker with you know ketchup oh I have
to use like these 20 tools to do this
thing that's not available yet because
they're too expensive but people
appreciate that because you're trying to
survive and figure it out I don't know
I'm just making this up but you know you
could pull inspiration like that and
when you add when you watch stuff and
ask yourself why did I transport myself
into that moment right now you can you
can learn and pick up a lot of things
too there's a a YouTuber who I remember
creating a video and it went viral and I
started to ask questions like can I
adopt that similar structure into one of
my videos this this video was uh was a
guy Lewis created a machine to slap a
chicken fast enough to see if it could
cook
okay so it was like can you cook a
chicken by slapping it you're like wait
what like I gotta open that up and it's
this machine that he built yeah but he
didn't just start building machine he
said why is this even a question we're
wondering well there are 20 years of
reddits talking about the mathematics
behind this and why it actually would be
possible but there is like nobody's
built the machine to figure it out so
I'm gonna do that yeah so he built this
thing and there's like a time lapse and
there's trial error things failing and
he actually does it or a lot of chickens
murdered
um I mean these were grocery store
chickens oh so they were already they're
already Frozen yeah as opposed to like
live chicken oh I slap a live chat it
would that would be a murder there's a
lot of yeah and there's a lot of tension
in this podcast episode because we've
had empathy for a lobster but now we're
over here just slaughtering chickens
people to vegetarian right now yeah this
is this is intense it's never happened
before on the podcast and Pokemon is
like animals oh my gosh this is just
like full circle does anyone ever die in
Pokemon no yeah so but they get they
they like they faint okay okay and they
go back in their Pokeball so they could
be revived later yeah yeah yeah
um wow there was a huge debate about
this when Pokemon came out they were
like they're like parents were not okay
with it anyway going back to which
animal were we on oh chicken chicken
slap in the grocery store chickens and
cooking them because they're slapped so
fast and it was such an intriguing video
that I was like are there any questions
in the Pokemon space that I could build
something for to find out the answer to
and there was there's there's these cars
that you can get graded and they the
cards still Shake inside of there and
there's been debate for years whether or
not that actually is damaging to the
cards so I was like I'm just gonna
follow act by act not frame by frame but
kind of yeah exactly what Lewis did but
I'm gonna build a machine out of Lego to
shake a Pokemon card and I'm gonna have
the same Arc of the story and I did it
and it went gangbusters wow and even
people who don't care about graded cards
just loved the way that was framed and
put together in like the time lapse of
me building a Lego with a motor to shake
a thing um and then I pulled from
Mythbusters at the end of that episode
too because you know Mythbusters they
they bust it but then they're like let's
just take it to the extreme so I got
like a jackhammer and I put a card on it
to shake like a hundred thousand times
per minute and it totally demolished the
card inside yeah which was just a fun
kind of gush at the end of the video so
so the unlock here is you're also if
you're kind of diversifying your
consumption and maybe learning from just
good storytelling in general Divergent
ideas in YouTube in general and kind of
Storytelling Frameworks then you can
pull those Frameworks and think about
how could I apply that to my niche of
real estate my Niche should be in a loan
officer as a fitness coach as someone
that's doing cooking videos as someone
who's vlogging and trying to figure out
bringing of course storytelling is the
essence of really making your your Vlog
take off and so you're pulling
storytelling principles from multiple
sources and then pulling them into what
you're doing Ryan you'll notice a lot of
Ryan Tran type things that I do in deep
pocket monster a lot of the
self-deprecation putting myself into
nervous situations which is genuine yeah
but we purposefully put ourselves in
those situations because we see that
that makes everything more human with
relation to Ryan's stuff uh and there's
some just like the one where he went to
go find a fossil so that he could like
the whole story was he he brought a
dinosaur bone to show and tell when he
was six but he lied and said it was it
was real when it was obviously plastic
and he said he like felt so bad about
that for years which he probably wasn't
even thinking about it day by day but it
was a good story I'm gonna go get a real
fossil I've found a fossil expert and
I'm gonna take it back to my teacher and
so I can like redeem myself as this evil
person and when I was six and just the
way that unfolds and he brings an expert
in who's like the guide in the hero's
story but then the the teacher he talks
about and and he rewards her with some
money at the end as a as a gift it
wasn't even about the money that was
like a nice surprise at the end I mean
he's just a genius with that stuff I I
would consume every Ryan Trahan
interview
um in addition to like any Mr Beast
interview because getting into their
brains for free is pretty amazing that's
powerful so I've got a final question
for you in a second but I want to
actually encourage listeners there's
some powerful episodes uh our last
year's conversation we'll link these all
up in the show notes a while back we
talked about email marketing you were
dropping bombs on that and do you think
email marketing is relevant in 2023 more
than ever yeah why do you say that
because we're so disconnected from all
the social platforms that we all follow
each other on that it's really hard to
have a personal conversation with
somebody and email is still the most
powerful way to just get into a person's
mind and and and help them or or or
encourage them to go in a different
direction you know direct messages are
great but you can only do or and reach
so many people on the day or at the same
time with the broadcast emails I I feel
like I feel like there's a huge
opportunity for so many creators who
just miss out and I think those who do
capitalize on email and building a list
are going to be way ahead of the game
because as we all know you know Tick
Tock could go away tomorrow Facebook
just laid off 10 000 people or meta
today and and like who knows yeah our
accounts that we're building up on other
people's sandboxes might be closed yeah
and so email if for anything Insurance
yeah right to stay connected to your
audience is important let alone the fact
that you could have an event come out
and just email everybody and say hey
tickets are now available and then you
know people buy them
um there's you gotta watch that video
yeah I love it I love it so if you were
if that Peaks your interest check out
the show notes because we've got uh past
episode talking all about email
marketing go deeper with that patch
dropped some very strategic episodes on
the think media podcast about more
YouTube strategy but as we land the
plane I'm just gonna play a quick round
of overrated underrated with you here
and curious about your take as a smart
entrepreneur and YouTube Creator some of
the YouTube features so YouTube
Community tab overrated or underrated
underrated we I use it all the time yeah
multiple times a day uh once or twice
per week I know there's some people who
use it daily yeah there are some things
that people say about utilizing that tab
thus then allowing for your other videos
to be seen more I'm not sure how much
that's true I think it was true at one
point with polls specifically I don't
know if that still works but it's about
Community let's communicate with the
people who are there and share some of
the fun Insider things that are
happening also put a timestamp on what's
going on in your business and and with
your audience uh it's a great way that
we let people know what's coming YouTube
stories is it rated at all I don't know
if anybody uses it I mean Dan and I on
my team we tested it we do get some
views and we do get some people coming
in but I think it's definitely
underutilized but it's not talked about
very much I mean I'm curious your take
on it yeah I think that YouTube stories
if you have to have 10 000 subscribers
assuming you do they last seven days and
you might as well do it once a week in
my opinion I because we pull thirty
thousand fifty thousand views on ours on
think media but one of the videos can
have a sticker so if anything you could
do a 15 second clip to just remind
somebody about something in your past
library with one clickable video and
it's gonna last seven days that's nice
so it's a might as well so it is a might
as well it's not like oh that's the
tactic that changed everything but if
you have if you're disciplined and you
throw some reminders on your calendar on
Tuesday Mornings which would be every
seven days at 8 45 in the morning my
Google Calendar tells me to post a
YouTube story and you post it yourself
and I post it myself and I say like hey
either something new or something passed
in the library because if you're getting
new subscribers yes YouTube
recommendations and maybe people will
dig but there's a lot of people won't
know it also does grow subscribers like
16 I mean at our size like 26 so that's
weird
um and it does give you the data and
then we always do a second story to say
by the way if you you didn't know we
have a podcast Channel you could do then
a sticker to another channel so I'm I'm
just not a fan of these sure you might
as well because any time you say yes to
a sure no offense but anytime you say
yes to a sure I might as well that's
time you're taking away from maybe
putting more effort into a better story
video a better story so you know I'm
very disciplined with my time yeah so
it's like I might as well but that
doesn't mean I should sure yeah and I
think the ROI of that makes sense there
is one other piece at scale if you have
somebody helping you on the social side
Brian on our team has also downloaded
like my Instagram stories which is kind
of where I Vlog so I basically Vlog
daily yeah it'd be called rise and grind
and so every day rise and grind and it's
coffee related in that yeah like rise
and grind coffee yes yeah and I mean
it's a little bit of rise and hustle but
you know family we have the same thing
it's it's definitely about I said I'm
imagining the logo and The Branding
already yeah so like rise and grab I've
been saying it for probably like five
years now and so whatever I will say
certain things on there that he then
just throws over on stories and then
that becomes a leverage to see that's
not you doing that's Brian doing which
is but it is me it's me that day on a
different platform on video and he
downloaded that additional the
additional work to get it to the other
correct is somebody else which is great
like if you can clone yourself or have
somebody do those things for you systems
team and whatever that was quite a bit
on on YouTube stories which are just not
rated we've decided those are not rated
overrated underrated uh creators
launching products Mr Beast festivals
Logan Paul KSI Prime underrated I think
you know you're mentioning all the big
names right on Prime's worth I don't
know how many billion now and beastables
is crazy we had our first at Walmart the
other day it's actually pretty good yeah
I gotta say it's not bad um only six
ingredients so okay that's that's cool
but I think for like the Creator who's
watching this or listening to this right
now there's always huge opportunities to
create something that can serve your
audience right and it doesn't have to be
huge it doesn't even have to be an
invention in like the switch pod which
was that was one of our answers to a
problem that myself Caleb and our
audience had at the time for
videographers there might be a coaching
program there might be a service that
you could offer and you don't have to go
big real fast in fact and will it Fly
it's about getting your first customer
and that's it because when you unlock
one you unlock more and the ability to
find one is much more it's there's a lot
less weight involved with finding one
person to help getting the result but
when you get that result and you unlock
that transformation for them it unlocks
a transformation in you because you go
wow I can actually do this I can
actually help somebody there's no
question anymore it's a fact and then
you almost feel responsible to go and
find other people it's almost your
obligation at that point overrated
underrated going Live on YouTube
underrated it's one of my favorite
things to do we went live when we hit
500 000 subscribers and we had
concurrently 5 000 people watching a
grown 40 year old man open Pokemon cards
with cartoons on them and uh it was the
it was just such good energy not just
for me but the people to be there in
support of this thing that they enjoy
and and to to be around the other nerds
that are like them right that's what I
talk about in super fans is you like
somebody needs to step up to create a
place for people to find people like
them and when you do that it only
enhances your brand it it because really
it's not even about you and and what
you're creating as far as like content
it's about the community and the
audience that can come and find other
people like them because really all
people want is to to feel like they
belong to something and that they're not
alone deeper on the live thing you went
live for over a thousand days in a row
on a big year in a row 365 365 days in a
row in a year on the pat Flynn Channel
with business content yeah during the
pandemic and that you know did not grow
my Channel just okay it was that
overrated or underrated that was
overrated for that's gonna grow your
channel and you're gonna get so many
views underrated for just how deep the
connections were made with the people
who continued to come and watch every
single day I have some people who still
reach out to me and say that the income
stream like saved them during the
pandemic it was the only thing regular
that they could look forward to during
that time and it's just again there's
there's not hundreds of thousands of
people saying that but you know a couple
hundred that matters did it change you
yes how so it changed me in
understanding that I didn't have to get
just views to be successful I got
loyalty during that time it also honed
in on my skills of going live and
creating content on the Fly really
really well it allowed me to get better
at storytelling just because I had a
platform every day to tell story on it
was purposefully stories as well
because stories I can just tell on the
Fly versus if it's a scripted
information piece that's that's I don't
have time if I'm going every day to
script every word so tell a story here
about that okay and then trust myself
just to tell it and then over time you
begin to learn strategies of what works
and what doesn't I got really efficient
I think you remember this there was a
virtual event that you created during
the pandemic after I've gone live for
you know 200 days or so and you and your
whole team was like you have multiple
camera angles like in your home with
like flyovers and zoom ins like how are
you doing this from your own office with
you were you were the best virtual
speaker at our event growth video live
virtual and as a solo creator with angle
switches the how you built your office
and it was a progression sound effect
yeah stream deck yep and uh that's
amazing a few years back as the creator
of smart passive income a huge audio
podcast courses on podcasting you've
helped a lot of people on podcasting you
told me you should absolutely not do
video podcasting because it'll divert
your focus and the audio experience or
in someone's ear there's that whole
intimacy we'll fast forward to today and
now there's youtube.com forward slash
podcast with NS things have changed Joe
Rogan podcast Logan Paul h3h3 value
attainment consumer uh call it a Samir
uh video podcasting overrated or
underrated and do you still believe you
shouldn't get on camera when doing a
podcast I think you should turn the
camera on when you're recording a
podcast even if it's Audio Only so that
you have that visual in case you want to
use it now if you really want a
successful video podcast you're going to
have to up the production more than just
turning on Squad cast and seeing the two
faces that said also having the camera
on allows you to take then really nice
clips that don't have to be super
produced but they're about a very
specific topic so I'm in the middle of
video podcasting because I was always
against it I was like video like that's
not what a regular Creator should do
right now even though Joe Rogan was huge
and still is and it's taking off
although he's on Spotify now sure uh but
I think for it's getting easier and
easier now to do it I think the
technology there makes it easy so that
it's it's not as hard
um it still is a separate media format
than the audio format and I think that
if you're going to do both you got to be
aware that you're either going to create
a really amazing audio experience that
and then the video is going to be second
hand and have to catch up to it or vice
versa and that's just mainly what's
happening now is it's primarily built
for the video and watching experience
but then you know a video that would
make a good video
is not going to necessarily have the
best audio for audio so if I could snap
my fingers and not have to like you know
work to create the content I would have
a video podcast for video and then I'd
have an audio podcast for audio got it
um overrated underrated tick tock
over in it
overrated underrated Instagram overrated
overrated underrated Facebook way
overrated overrated underrated YouTube
underrated YouTube's underrated yeah
still yeah oh yeah what do you think the
future of YouTube is I I don't know how
to answer that question all I know is
it's going to be continually trying to
get better at feeding the right videos
to the right people and if you are a
Creator who has a message to share and
you get good at sharing that message
YouTube will do the work to find those
people for you Pat Flynn uh what do you
want to shout out and promote think
media podcast of course lots of
resources the past episodes is a library
of gold but it's good to grab a journal
especially the email marketing episode
because it's so tactical and you share a
lot of actionable things there many of
Pat Pat's books I'm kind of telling them
your things but super fans is one of my
favorite books in fact I actually think
what we're going to do is release I was
just I was going through my mind we
sunsetted our Inner Circle program but
it was amazing you taught super fans and
I think maybe we'll just drop that maybe
somewhere exclusively to our VRA
Community or maybe on the podcast but
you have other conversations out there
where you taught super fans besides all
of those resources and check out the
show notes Pat Flynn where can people
check you out thank you Sean thank you
everybody so our biggest thing right now
in SPI this might be interesting for you
we could we could jam on this later is
is you know we've had dozens of courses
created over time and many of them have
helped thousands of people uh we were
beginning to notice that the completion
rates of those courses were dwindling
and especially during the pandemic and
this makes sense people weren't getting
the ability to have the motivation to
just go through those courses on their
own so what we've since created is
something called the all access pass
where we now sell
access to all of our courses but access
to all the courses wouldn't be valuable
that's actually more overwhelming what
you get is you actually get a guide and
pathways through the courses that are
right for you so you can actually make
your own path through the courses so if
you're a podcaster for example you take
our power up podcasting course you
graduate from there go to our second
level course maybe you want to now start
building an email list go to the email
marketing course maybe you now want to
do video uh podcasting cool take that
workshop and you can go through those
Lanes in the way that works best for you
but what is really a hit right now is
these things called accelerators so we
have a teacher come in to teach an
entire group of people going through one
of those courses at the same time
cohorts cohorts yeah but it's
asynchronous you don't have to show up
to a call to learn the lessons you take
the lesson on your own during that week
but you just go through those first two
because that's what everybody's assigned
now there's accountability and the
completion rates are off the charts and
the feedback has been like amazing so
I'm just proud of my team for figuring
out a solution to take all this
knowledge and package it in a way that
teaches still has some cohort based
status but is also asynchronous enough
for everybody's busy schedules so I'm
very proud of that because that's the
big thing we've been working on on SPI
the past that sounds amazing so
definitely take some time to get to the
show notes of this episode to access
some of these resources Pat Flynn check
them out all on social media and deep
pocket monster let's get our Pokemon on
and uh man I appreciate you thanks so
much for coming back on the show